hi everyone I'm Dana jevin and they say
you got to know when to hold them and
know when to fold them right well this
New Year's Eve next star hits the
jackpot and is counting down to 2023 in
Las Vegas High Roller style now our
sponsor yamava Resort and Casino with a
taste of the Sweet Life
[Music]
if luxury is on your list yamaba Resort
and Casino is more than just a place to
stay bathtubs and bubbly The Sweet Life
could be yours whoa
count down with us
foreign
[Music]
we have over 7 100 slots which is more
than anywhere in the west go big or go
home or stay at yamava where the casino
floor is over 300 000 square feet you
want to go play some slots yeah let's
get asked cover those 300 000 square
feet and keep the hot Street going from
SoCal to Sin City
you don't have to be a high roller to
make a splash at Palms pools double down
on fun or just have some r r here's
Michael
happy 2023
so we are very very excited to be
reaching out into the community and
bringing the gaming Hospitality warmth
and friendliness to Las Vegas the
promise first opens its doors on
November 15 2001 and recently sold to
the San Manuel band of mission Indians
making it the first Las Vegas casino
owned by a Native American tribe
we are inside the two-bedroom penthouse
suite where glamor looks good on anyone
Michael I could so get used to this the
rooms are very unique it's one of the
real true standout aspects of the Palms
that makes us very special and really
rather intimate I know this place is
1900 square feet but where are you
Mickey we have the blush Suite which is
the perfect girls party Suite we have
sweets that are more like the man cave
and then we have the cinema room we have
a basketball Suite we have the Kingpin
with two Bowling Lanes in it forget
about the pressures of figuring out New
Year's plans because we are high above
it all join us for next star's Las Vegas
countdown to New Year's Eve the hottest
place to be there will be lots to oon
about as the ball drops so don't have
fomo make us your hot date